[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition des matins du sénat je
vous propose aujourd'hui de nous
interroger sur le monde d'après
notamment via cette audition de france
team hermans le vice président de la
commission européenne
avec la fin de la crise du coronavirus
qui se profile une question se fait jour
quelles ambitions voulons nous porter au
niveau européen en matière d'écologie
certains voudraient remettre en cause le
green deal européen qui vise la
neutralité carbone d'ici 2050
mais le vice président de la commission
européenne l'a redit l'urgence a
augmenté avec la crise ducobu 19
le sujet est d'ailleurs sur la table des
27 pour le conseil européen qui se tient
ces jours-ci mais alors vous allez
l'entendre certains questionnent les
décisions de la commission européenne
à l'image du président l ère de la
commission des affaires européennes du
sénat jean bizet la commission
européenne va trop loin at il dit vous
allez voir cet échange dans cette
audition préparer aujourd'hui pour
public sénat par louis mollier sa baie
et mathilde mutarelli madame la
présidente président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et députés
c'est un grand plaisir d'être avec vous
aujourd'hui j'ai toujours beaucoup
apprécié aussi dans mes autres fonctions
les relations avec le parlement français
parce que pour pouvoir développer nos
politiques
on a vraiment besoin de votre soutien et
de votre compréhension pour ce que nous
faisons est aussi que vous nous aidiez à
définir la politique
vous savez très bien que les suites du
grenat virus ont plongé notre économie
dans une récession inédite
je crois qu'on voit réagir fortement et
de manière solidaire afin d'éviter que
cette prise d'un doute heath un coût
social économique et politique
exorbitants à travers notamment les
faillites d'entreprises et de la
dégradation du marché de travail
l'union européenne a déjà pris des
décisions importantes pour aider les
gouvernements les entreprises et les
citoyens
par exemple à travers l'assouplissement
des fonds structurels ou encore notre
proposition de mécanismes contribution
au système du chômage partiel
le 27 mai dernier
on a proposé un plan de relance européen
ambitieux en utilisant d'endettement
commun et notre budget européen
pluriannuel pour apporter dès maintenant
une réponse commune forte à la hauteur
de la crise exceptionnelle que nous
connaissons ce plan mais la met l'accent
sur trois enjeux essentiels pour
l'avenir de l'économie européenne
la transition verte la transition
numérique et la résilience nos économies
comme vous le savez il sera dès cette
semaine discuté par les chefs d'état de
gouvernement et j'espère vraiment qu'il
y aura une décision
au cours du mois de juillet pour pouvoir
commencer parce que si on perd trop de
temps
on ne sera pas en mesure de réagir
maintenant que le chômage augmente et
que beaucoup d'entreprises sont en
difficulté notre stratégie vise à
transformer l'union européenne en une
société prospère et juste dotée d'une
économie moderne compétitive et efficace
efficace dans l'utilisation des
ressources atteignant la nettoie les
minutes khalid et climatique
à l'horizon de 2050 et découplant la
croissance économique de l'utilisation
des ressources
le pacte vert reste notre boussole
il ya un échange et l'urgence a même
augmenté ici septembre nous publierons
notre étude d'impact pour devenir de
nous définir de nouveaux objectifs de
réduction des émissions à l'horizon de
2030 donc l'analyse que nous faisons
c'est entre -50 % et - 55%
on va pas aller au delà de ça parce que
je suis comme un bon premièrement je
n'ai pas de mandat de faire une autre
analyse deuxièmement politiquement il
serait impossible de trouver un accord
ni au parlement européen ni au sein du
conseil un accord qui irait au delà du
moins 55%
donc on vise là dessus et je crois que
c'est possible
pour ce qui est de la position du sénat
sur l'instrument je lui dis que nous
avons proposé je vous dis franchement
que pour la commission européenne ce qui
compte c'est de pouvoir établir le
trajectoire
pour être sûrs que nous arrivons à
disons moins 55 ans en 2030 et 0 2050 et
qu'on peut adapter le trajectoire si on
ait besoin
on a proposé de faire sa part par actes
délégués
mais franchement pour moi ce n'est pas
un principe fondamental de la
proposition si le parlement européen qui
a une opinion négative là dessus si les
parlements nationaux comme votre sauna
et aussi on avait eu le même départ aux
pays-bas sont opposés à cet instrument
je ne serais pas contre a changé
l'instrument à vent mais il faut quand
même assurer qu'on aura la possibilité
de trouver un accord sur la trajectoire
et sans que cela pourrait être arrêté
par un état membre il faut quand même
essayer de trouver des décisions par
majorité qualifiée sinon je crains pour
cette trajectoire
bon notre projet de relance propose de
mettre la double transition verte
numérique au coeur des investissements à
réaliser les plans nationaux soumis par
les états membres ou bénéficier des bons
de des fonds de la facilité de reprise
de résilience
on parle de 560 milliards d'euros
contribueront à la transition verte
ils devront notamment se conformer aux
plans nationaux énergie climat réduisant
au niveau national les objectifs 2030
donc c'est aussi une conséquence la
décision de septembre sur l'objectif
2030 la puissant puissance de feu de
notre programme d'investissement invest
in your qui servent 4 catalyseur pour
l'investissement privé sera accrue
notamment pour contribuer au financement
d'infrastructures soutenable à des
investissements dans les secteurs
stratégiques
le font d'autres asie transition juste
sera porté à 40 milliards d'euros le
fonds structurels
les fonds structurels comme le fonds
agricole seront également renforcés et
contribueront à atteindre les objectifs
du pacte vert
je vois je vois l'agriculture comme un
allié pas un adversaire et on doit
donner à nos agriculteurs une
perspective beaucoup meilleure que celle
qu'ils ont maintenant et notamment dans
le premier pilier
l'argent n'arrive pas chez les
agriculteurs très souvent il arrive chez
les propriétaires et il faut quand même
qu'on est con et attention pour la
position financière des agriculteurs
eux-mêmes ceux qui travaillent dans
l'agriculture et pas uniquement ce qui
est trop souvent maintenant le cas pour
les propriétaires bon une chose est
claire
après cette crise nous ne pouvons pas
nous permettre de simplement
reconstituer d'économie du monde d'avant
réaliser maintenant des investissements
qui deviendront des actifs échoué dans
quelques années car ils ne sont pas
compatibles avec notre objectif de
neutralité climatique et la protection
de l'environnement n'aurait pas de sens
et provoquerait un gâchis considérable
pour nous comme pour les générations
futures
on fait on fait des emprunts maintenant
pour le pour sortir de cette crise mais
qu'est-ce que quelle est la proposition
pour nos enfants on met encore un poids
plus lourd sur leurs épaules
mais pour quelle société je dirais une
société plus juste une société
soutenable
nous avons devoir de reconstruire notre
économie sur la sur des bases plus
saines et plus durable respectueuse des
limites de notre planète
il ne s'agit pas seulement de protéger
notre santé notre environnement pour
nous et nos enfants mais aussi de
moderniser notre appareil productif pour
assurer notre prospérité et mettre
l'europe de nos entreprises en position
de leader dans les secteurs ils feront
l'économie de demain
vous savez très bien tirés de l'otan et
moi même qu'on travaille là-dessus jour
et nuit
la résilience européennes doit être
renforcé une fois que moins naïf sur sur
le comportement de nos partenaires dans
d'autres parties du monde et il faut
quand même avoir la possibilité de
protéger notre industrie quand elle fait
quand elle va dans la bonne direction
et les autres ne le font pas donc
corriger ça aux frontières devient une
proposition impérative pour la
commission on retiendra les delay délais
et on verra par secteur quelles seraient
les mesures nécessaires pour éviter la
fuite de carbon et pour éviter une
concurrence fausses sur la base de
politiques qui ne mène pas à la
neutralité climatique
bon je dois dire deux mots encore sur
l'énergie nous devons aussi priorité des
projets d'investissement dans le domaine
des énergies renouvelables qui autrement
risque de souffrir fortement de la crise
ainsi que l'investissement dans
l'hydrogène propres pour laquelle nous
préparons une stratégie spécifique qui
sera présenté d'ici 15 jours et je
n'insiste on n'a pas rien contre le
nucléaire mais j'espère que tout le
monde fasse un calcul et disons purement
économique
est ce un investissement raisonnable si
le prix des énergies renouvelables
continuent à baisser
il faut quand même faire ce calcul aussi
sur une trajectoire assez long mais j'ai
rien contre l'énergie nucléaire je sais
que le présent visait avec cette
question la mobilité propre constitue un
autre axe essentiel notamment le soutien
aux véhicules propres et la mise en
place de points de recharge pour les
véhicules électriques mais aussi les
transports urbains en commun et
j'assiste à dessus hein on a vraiment un
grand problème partout en europe dans
les villes et dans les territoires su
avec nos transports en commun et on doit
vraiment relancer les transports en
commun pour éviter vraiment qu'on aille
dans la fosse direction enfin nous
devons investir dans l'économie
circulaire qui aidera notre système
économique et devenir économie en
ressources mais aussi plus résilients et
je dois vraiment dire que le discours du
président de la république dimanche
dernier
m'a vraiment donné à force encore
d'insister sur le pacte vert et sur les
projets de la commission et je vois la
france comme un des alliés les plus
importants dans cette lutte qui sera
tellement important pour l'avenir de
notre société et pour pour nos enfants
et encore une fois pour les accords
commerciaux du futur il faudra quand
même repenser système et je crois qu'on
peut exiger de nos partenaires
internationaux
ils suivent aussi un trajectoire qui
mène à l'accomplissement de désaccord de
paris et à la neutralité climatique vers
la moitié du siècle
merci beaucoup pour votre attention et
si vous avez d'autres questions je suis
à votre disposition
ce micro est encore coupée
cher sabine en ne tentant pas à l'eau
vous m'entendez
oui ça y est ça y est bon véronique rit
autant de la république en marche
merci madame la présidente tout d'abord
comme c'est la première fois que je
prends la parole dans notre commission
depuis que j'ai été élu je souhaite
remercier mes collègues pour la
confiance qu'ils viennent de m'accorder
lors de l'élection au poste de vice
présidente de la commission du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire
je suis honoré de servir notre
commission et prêt-à-porter évidemment
avec ambition nos combats liés à la
transition écologique
monsieur le vice-président timerman
merci pour vos propos liminaire nous
avons accueilli avec une grande
satisfaction pacte vert pour l'europe
que vous avez présenté en décembre 2019
la crise sanitaire à laquelle nous
venons de faire face à déstabiliser nos
agendas législatif mais l'ambition reste
la même la relance doit être verte vous
l'avais dit au risque de faire face dans
les prochaines décennies à des
bouleversements plus important encore
que ce que nous venons de connaître
comme l'ont souligné plusieurs ministres
de l'environnement dans leur tribune
adressée à l'union européenne cette
sortie de crise appelle des solutions de
long terme qui dépasse le simple cadre
de la relance économique et à ce titre
les citoyens ont réaffirmé à plusieurs
mises leur souhait de voir renforcer la
souveraineté politique économique de la
france et plus largement de l'union
européenne soit que nous partageons en
tant que représentant du peuple
avec mes collègues de la république en
marche nous oeuvrons depuis maintenant
trois ans pour que nos paroles se
concrétise en actes et ne reste pas
lettre morte
en ce sens nous voulons que cette
promotion de nos souverainetés
nationales européennes deviennent
réalité dans notre monde où des systèmes
de production de consommation sont très
globalisé la commission européenne at
elle entamé des travaux à la suite de la
crise sanitaire pour assurer cette
souveraineté
comment intégrer pleinement l'empreinte
carbone et les émissions importés dans
les
du pacte vert co rapporteur de la loi
française anti gaspillage pour une
économie circulaire la france a adopté
un nombre important de mesures qui
donnent une trajectoire ambitieuse en
matière d'économie circulaire
pour autant j'ai été interpellé pendant
mes travaux par le risque de distorsion
au principe de libre circulation des
biens face à des mesures pourtant faveur
de la transition écologique qui aurait
pu nous empêcher de leur donner un
caractère obligatoire par le la de
l'information du consommateur compteur
busage le point vert pour n'en citer que
quelques-uns dans ce cadre la sq un
critère verts ambitieux au même titre
qu'il existât critères sanitaires pour
justifier le retour des barrières aux
échanges de marchandises
pourrait-il être élaboré je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup sur collègue jean
françois rapin sénateurs les
républicains bien mesdames et messieurs
les présidents monsieur le commissaire
quelques mots merci de vos différentes
présentations
j'aimerais insister sur le volet
agricole du green deal rappelant que le
green deal et l'idée du green deal dans
sa dimension budgétaire et les premières
intentions qui lui ont été portés sont
arrivés avant la crise donc entre 30
entre temps nous avons eu à vivre une
crise sanitaire conséquente que vous
connaissez tous donc si l'on en croit la
commission aujourd'hui la double
stratégie biodiversité et de la ferme à
table qui est adapté bien sûr au ring il
représenterait un nouveau secteur
agricole davantage pour le secteur
agricole davantage d'opportunités que de
contraintes
or ces opportunités dans l'état actuel
des choses à mon sens reste à confirmer
par contre les contraintes on les voit
essentiellement pour pour nos
agriculteurs avec des efforts qui sont
considérables d'ici à d'ici à 2030 avec
des efforts considérables bien sûr dans
dans l'évolution des techniques et des
technologies mais avec des efforts
considérables aussi au travers le budget
accordé à l'agriculture et
nous avons travaillé dans les
différentes commissions dans lesquelles
je suis retrouvé en tout cas commission
des finances et commission des affaires
européennes sur le cadre financier
pluriannuel et sa réforme récente et une
rallonge de 15 milliards d'euros sur le
sur le deuxième pilier en particulier ça
nous laisse à penser qu'aujourd'hui la
politique agricole plus qu'une politique
économique telle qu'on la voyait devient
une politique environnementale
dont acte pourquoi pas mais en tout cas
il faudra lui donner les moyens parce
que cette transformation devra se faire
non pas au détriment des agriculteurs
mais alors avantage l'espère je le
disais tout à l'heure et je terminerai
larmes
les adaptations de cette politique
nouvelles vont se faire dans un contexte
qui est celui d'une crise sanitaire en
tout cas au sortir d'une crise sanitaire
et donc toutes les politiques qui
étaient mises en oeuvre au préalable à
mon avis devront être revisitée pour ne
pas trop fragilisé notre agriculture en
tout cas en tout cas l'agriculture
européenne
et s'il en est l'agriculture nationale
française
rappelons la crise du coc vide bien sûr
avec un soutient d'emblée de l'europe
qui est quand même resté très très
discret des accords commerciaux qui ont
été noués notamment avec le mexique ceux
du mercosur aussi sur lesquelles on va
devoir probablement revenir il faudra
quand même quelques quelques précisions
sur la façon dont ils vont être mises en
oeuvre
et rappelons le des marchés qui sont
aujourd'hui encore défavorable dans le
cadre de l'agriculture
je dirais de proximité avec un combat
face aux industriels et aux
distributeurs qui est qui est important
donc moi ce que je crains c'est que
demain on a une agriculture et une
production qui soit à deux vitesses une
pour les riches de très grande qualité
certes
dans les états européens et puis une
agriculture qui viendraient une
production qui viendrait des pays tiers
qui serait une agriculture peut-être à
bas coût qui permettrait aux plus
pauvres de se nourrir parce que les
produits sortis est issu de cette
agriculture serait moins cher donc voilà
je voulais avoir des éclairages sur 7
sur sur cette vision des choses monsieur
le commissaire je vous remercie venir
bernard deflesselles député les
républicains oui merci madame la
présidente monsieur le président chers
collègues du sénat et de l'assemblée
monsieur le vice-président je suis en
charge du rapport de la commission des
affaires européennes de l'assemblée
rapporte la neutralité carbone de 25 ans
et vous pensez bien que je partage vos
ambitions se portait bien sûr le nom de
la commission européenne alors ses
ambitions vous les portez évidemment
avec la présidente van der leyen et vous
avez ni maintenant quelques mois l'idée
de faire en sorte 25% seraient consacrés
bien sûr à la transition
environnementale en est en pleine
discussion du cfp du cadre financier
pluriannuel avec la sellette ont 100
milliards dans cette lancée
tiendrez-vous ces conditions budgétaires
et évidemment après la crise du coc vide
il ya des vents contraires on sait très
bien ils viennent du taux de l'est et de
certains lobbys
ma deuxième question effort soit la loi
climat vous il y avait fait allusion est
en discussion au parlement européen nous
avons missionné tout récemment président
de la commission nous avons suivi avec
attention le rapport de madame bilan et
c'est vrai qu'ils souhaitent réhaussé
des ambitions à 60 65 % dit que c'est
compliqué aux oraux de la commission
c'est pourtant les objectifs portés par
le giec
avec un point de passage également 2040
à 80 ou 85% donc ses objectifs sont-ils
de nabeul à vos yeux
et puis il ya une autre question qui
vient immédiatement derrière c'est
l'application de la neutralité
climatique à chaque état membre
car aujourd'hui une part l'ong collectif
des 27 mai la commission et très
allantes sur l'idée de faire en sorte
que chaque pays portent son ca pourquoi
neutralité climatique
pensez-vous de ce point de vue là qu'un
compromis soit possible enfin vous
propose un mécanisme d'inclusion carbone
aux frontières comment avancer les
négociations et enfin sur le front de
transition juste
il ya malheureusement très sensible de
ce fonds de 10 milliards à 40 milliards
dans la dernière et pure du catherine
ancien du real hier quelle répartition
voyez vous entre les états merci
monsieur
merci jean yves le conte sénateurs
socialistes et républicains
merci madame la présidente merci
monsieur le vice président de la
commission 5,5 question la première
monsieur le vice-président pensez vous
qu'avec le plan de relance et les
perspectives de cadre financier
pluriannuel actuelle vous avez les
moyens de convaincre les pays
récalcitrants à une amélioration des
objectifs d'émissions des gaz à effet de
serre f à échéance 2030
deuxième question le plan de relance qui
va être très largement concentré sur la
période 2020 2024 pour faire redémarrer
notre économie est quand même
relativement dans le court terme c'est à
dire que par rapport aux objectifs de
2030 et de neutralité carbone en 2050
on a besoin d'avoir des politiques de
long terme comment donc arriver sur le
long terme à mobiliser des financements
privés pour continuer les efforts et le
financement de ce pacte vert la
taxonomie pourra-t-elle être une d'une
aide certaines comment pourra-t-elle
évoluer au fur et à mesure des périodes
enfin comment est-ce que nous pourrons
peut-être envisager la pondération des
fonds propres des banques pour améliorer
la prise en compte des actifs écologique
troisième question considérez vous que
le traité actuel font dans l'union
européenne son article 194 qui qui pose
le droit des états membres à choisir
leur mix énergétique est compatible avec
nos objectifs de neutralité carbone
quatrième question pensez vous que les
accords commerciaux qui sont signés ou
qui sont en cours de négociation sont
réellement un atout ou au contraire un
handicap par rapport à nos objectifs de
neutralité carbone
enfin dernière question nous avons
aujourd'hui à peu près 50% de
l'équivalent nous important à peu près
l'équivalent de 50% des émissions de
l'union européenne avec nos produits des
produits importés aujourd'hui nous
voulons faire des relocalisations c'est
à dire que ça engendrera de nouvelles
émissions carbone sur le territoire
européen
comment faire en sorte que ceux-ci
n'aggrave pas les difficultés à
atteindre les objectifs pour 2030 et la
neutralité carbone à échéance 2050 je
vaux
merci merci nadia essayons député modem
main merci merci pour votre présentation
le parlement européen adoptée l'état
d'urgence climatique en novembre 2019 et
le pacte vert doit répondre à cette
urgence et mettre l'europe sur la
trajectoire de neutralité carbone et de
l'accord de paris
l'industrie alimentaire et mes 25 à 30%
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
dans le monde selon le rapport du giec
d'ailleurs sur l'évolution du climat
pour répondre aux objectifs ambitieux du
pacte vers les états membres de fond
réduire de moitié vous l'avez dit les
usagers exposition aux pesticides d'ici
2030 réforme de la pac stratégie de la
ferme à table les agriculteurs sont au
centre des préoccupations
à cet égard la commission européenne a
dévoilé sa stratégie et a affirmé que
l'alimentation européenne est réputée
sûre nutritives et de qualité élevée
elle devrait donc constituer désormais
la norme mondiale en matière de
durabilité et la stratégie de la ferme à
la table 10 rares encourager une
consommation alimentaire durable saine
et abordable pour tous cette stratégie
de la firme à la table propose ainsi un
plan d'action pour répondre à ces deux
objectifs de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et de sécurité
alimentaire vous l'avez souligné
l'europe de demain ne se fera pas sans
les agriculteurs mais ne pouvons pas
toujours demander plus à nos
agriculteurs si ces exigences les
empêche d'être compétitif et de vivre de
leur travail
le pacte vert en définissant une
stratégie européenne met en avant
certains objectifs de bon sens qui font
l'unanimité comme le renforcement du
pouvoir des agriculteurs dans les
chaînes alimentaires
cependant rien n'est précisé sur la
manière de les atteindre à l'opposé des
objectifs précis et contraignants sont
fixés sur la réduction de l'utilisation
des pesticides et des fertilisants des
ventes d'antimicrobiens etc
le groupe mouvement démocrate et
apparentés souhaite donc vous
interpeller sur ces deux questions
comment concilier l'ensemble des
objectifs affichés
alors que nous n'avons toujours pas de
véritable solution alternative pour bon
nombre d' usage de produits
phytosanitaires et quelle place pour une
agriculture écologique intensive qui
permet le maintien d'un accès à tous à
une
mentation de qualité et à des prix
abordables tout en assurant à juste
revenu à nos agriculteurs
je vous remercie merci anne catherine
loisier sénateur union centriste
merci mesdames messieurs les présidents
alors je vais passer très vite sur ma ma
première question que ce qu'elle a déjà
été posée sur le volet de l'agriculture
mais je voulais juste te revenir sur vos
propos monsieur le président puisque moi
il me semble que depuis 2015 les dpb ne
sont plus perçus par les propriétaires
mais parler fermi en tout cas en tant
que propriétaire je serais très
intéressé si j'avais des choses à
récupérer mais voilà depuis 2015 c'est
bien le fermier qui récupère les primes
versées par la pac mon sujet principal
ce serait plutôt celui de la filière
forêt bois est de savoir comment cette
filière vertueuse et prises en compte
dans les réflexions du plan de relance
tant sur le volet du soutien au matériau
bois dans la construction avec tout
l'enjeu d'une transe fixe d'une
transition écologique dans le bâtiment ô
combien vecteur nous savons de pollution
mais aussi pour tout le soutien aux
stratégies de reboisement et donc de
captation carbone sur l'ensemble des
territoires aux stratégies de
relocalisation de l'industrie du bois
qui nous le savons permet de proposer
des emplois de proximité non
délocalisables la filière forêt-bois me
semble-t-il en tout cas selon deux
rapports allons démontrer c'est un un
secteur incontournable et décisif pour
atteindre les objectifs de politiques
publiques essentielles de l'union
européenne à savoir à la fois la lutte
contre les changements climatiques mais
aussi la neutralité carbone
donc comment monsieur le président le
prenez-vous en compte dans vos
réflexions
merci merci fred avec du match député
liberté et territoires merci madame la
présidente monsieur le vice président
le plan de relance présenté fin mai par
la commission assiste comme vous l'avez
rappelé sur le lien entre relance
économique et construction d'une
économie résiliente à long terme
l'instrument de facilité pour la résine
ans et la relance qui a pour objectif
d'accélérer la transition des états
membres absorbe à lui seul 560 des 750
milliards d'euros du plan les états
membres qui souhaiteront bénéficier des
aides devront présenter un plan de
relance national
compatible avec les priorités
stratégiques de l'union européenne
notamment le pacte vert
les plans de relance devront être
cohérents avec les plans nationaux en
matière d'énergie et de climat et les
plans nationaux pour une transition
juste
ce sont donc les grands objectifs comme
vous l'avez rappelé de manière
pragmatique comme beaucoup de questions
ont été posées pour vous quelle est la
meilleure méthode pour évaluer les
besoins structurels de chaque état
permettant la résilience donc les
capacités de relance faut-il des
critères sur mesure qu'elles doivent
peut-être pour vous les outils
d'évaluation et de contrôle qui
permettront s'assurer que l'ambition
environnementale soit bien prise en
compte de manière effective
enfin la commission européenne entend
également faire de sa vague de
rénovation énergétique un pilier de la
relance posco vide
comment imaginez vous que cela puisse se
matérialiser je vous remercie
merci monsieur le fils président tim
airlines après cette première série des
questions vous avez la parole c'est la
première série
vous êtes très demandé quand on parle de
ce qu'on parle de sucre est ce que nous
recherchons à la commission européenne
ce et renforcer la résilience des
sociétés européennes et de nos économies
thierry breton parle souvent des
écosystèmes économique et je crois qu'il
a raison il faut analyser quelles sont
les écosystèmes économique qui auront
besoin d'une majeure souveraineté
européenne au pouvoir garantir aussi
bien la transition écologique mais aussi
éviter une perte d'emplois et créer un
environnement économique en europe qui
puisse concret avec les résumant sur des
conditions sociales et environ un talent
qui relève de nos valeurs fondamentales
donc c'est pour ça que nous visons tout
le système maintenant et que nous ferons
des propositions secteur par secteur
beaucoup de questions sur la pac et
j'aimerais quand même clarifier que la
transition doit être soutenue par une
pac axée sur le pacte vert on n'a pas le
choix on ne peut pas continuer avec la
pac comme elle est à l'heure actuelle la
nouvelle pac qu'on a proposé en juin
2018 vise à aider les agriculteurs à
améliorer la performance
environnementale et grâce à un modèle
davantage axée sur les résultats
une meilleure utilisation des données et
analyse une amélioration des normes
environnementales obligatoire nouvelles
mesures volontaires et orientations
accrue des investissements vers des
technologies et pratiques écologiques et
numérique là je crois que le numérique
peut aider la grèce
la culture d'une manière inouïe elle
vise au également à leur garantir un
revenu décent qui leur permettent de
pouvoir aux besoins de leurs familles et
de résister aux crises en tous genres
l'obligation d'améliorer l'efficacité et
l'efficience des paiements directs en
plafonnant l'aide au revenu et en
l'orientant mieux vers des agriculteurs
qui en ont besoin et qu'ils sont à la
hauteur de l'ambition écologique plutôt
que vers les entités et société qui
possède simplement des terres agricoles
c'est un élément essentiel à mon avis de
la future pac et on n'est pas même pas
là avec les changements depuis 2015 la
capacité des états membres et veiller au
respect de cette obligation sera
soigneusement évalué dans les plans
stratégiques et contrôlés durant toute
leur mise en oeuvre
il ressort des conclusions de la
dernière analyse effectuée par la
commission que la réforme peut
effectivement
courir à la réalisation du pacte vert
pourvu
pourvu que les dispositions essentielles
des propositions formulées survivent au
processus de négociation et qu'il
conviendrait d'apporter certaines
améliorations et de prendre des
initiatives concrètes et c'est pour ça
je crois que il faut maintenir nos
ambitions budgétaires et j'espère qu'on
aura un résultat positif au mois de
juillet et je compte sur le soutien aux
je compte sur un compromis qui
soutiennent le principe est en effet le
fonds de transition juste a été augmenté
à 40 milliards d'euros c'est vraiment
pour aider des régions 1 qui ont une un
retard énorme dans domaine surtout
énergétiques et industrielles de faire
une transition de manière de pouvoir
trouver des nouvelles de nouveaux
emplois et de nouvelles activités
économiques et ça revient aux états
membres de discuter avec nous quelles
seraient les régions visées et les
secteurs visés on a déjà identifié sa
part et amant quand on était à 7,5
milliards d'euros mais dont il faudra
réviser certains aspects de cela
maintenant qu'on est à 40 milliards
alors le le pour le financement privé je
suis assez optimiste parce que quand on
parle avec le secteur bancaire et les
investisseurs privés
ils ont une crainte énorme de perdre des
fonds dans des investissements qui l'ont
qui n'ont pas de futur donc là il ya
vraiment un changement d'attitude qui
nous aide énormément pour aller dans la
direction verte
mais la taxonomie de prêts à aider c'est
pour ça qu'on fera des propositions
ultérieure d'ici la fin de l'année
je ne vois pas d'inconvénients dans
l'article 194 mais je reviendrai sur
cette question que je vais étudier la
question
j'ai pas de réponse à vous donner
concrètement maintenant oui j'ai déjà
dit on va revoir les accords commerciaux
c'est nécessaire il ya une poussée
sociétal partout dans les états membres
je vous donne l'exemple de mon propre
pays ou
les accords commerciaux ça n'était même
pas un sujet politique
c'était toujours d'accord laisser ça aux
experts mais non dans la société
néerlandaise s'est hautement discuter il
faut quand même on se rendre compte en
tant que politique que les accords
commerciaux c'est pas comme par le passé
maintenant les gens veulent vraiment que
ces accords soutiennent nos valeurs
soutiennent la protection sociale
soutiennent la protection
environnementale donc on a pas mal de
boulot à faire avec nos partenaires
internationaux les forêts les forêts
c'est tellement important parce que on
veut on veut vraiment développer une
stratégie scientifiquement soutenu pour
l'arrêt forestation pour éviter la
déforestation surtout des forêts comment
on dit aux français primaire je connais
pas le mot exact
les originaires jusqu'à et surtout en
pologne en d'autres pays et de créer un
équilibre entre le potentiel économique
de ce secteur est en même temps le
potentiel écologique du secteur qui est
également incroyable non seulement dans
les régions rurales mais aussi dans les
régions urbaines
donc on sortira avec une stratégie
l'année prochaine et je crois que ça ira
dans la direction voulue par vous voilà
je m'arrête dénoncent comme ça je
voudrais encore l'occasion de poser
d'autres questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le vice
président andré gattolin sénateurs la
république en marchant oui merci madame
la présidente mes chers collègues
monsieur qui me sert tout d'abord je
tiens à saluer votre énergie votre
combativité parce que on le sait ce
pacte vert ne va pas de soi en tous les
cas pas seulement auprès de certains
états mais auprès de certains groupes
plus obscurs et vous tenez bon et vous
avez raison alors dans un rapport très
récent en date du 5 juin dernier la cour
des comptes de l'union européenne a
conclu je cite le déclin de la db
biodiversité des terres agricoles se
poursuit aujourd'hui
malgré des mesures ci
bhl est prise dans le cadre de la pac
est le constat qui est fait dans ce
rapport est lourd puisque on souligne
des lacunes dans la stratégie européenne
en faveur de la biodiversité à l'horizon
2020 qui n'avait fixé aucun objectif
mesurable concernant l'agriculture on
soulève aussi une mauvaise coordination
de la pac
on soulève aussi que certains régimes de
la pac offre un plus grand potentiel
d'amélioration de la biodiversité mais
que la commission et les états membres
ont privilégié les options à faible
impact est pire que tout la commissi la
cour des comptes de l'union européenne
jugent que le suivi et l'évaluation par
la commission des dépenses de la pac
dédiée à la biodiversité et je cite pas
fiable alors comment est il possible
notamment que des indicateurs en matière
de biodiversité comme celle sur la
diversité génétique du bétail qui date
de 2005 n'est pas été réactualisé depuis
15 ans comment monsieur le commissaire
comptez vous assurez un suivi plus
précis des dépenses budgétaires et
assurer des indicateurs de meilleure
fiabilité pour évaluer l'incidence de la
pac sur la biodiversité
enfin comment comptez-vous plus
généralement répondre recommandations de
la cour des comptes européenne pour
mieux coordonner la nouvelle stratégie
en faveur de la biodiversité avec la
prochaine politique agricole commune en
gestation
afin d'accroître les contributions des
paiements directs et du développement
rural à la biodiversité des terres
agricoles je vous remercie
[Musique]
merci libri cours député udi indépendant
merci madame présidente chers collègues
on ne peut que se féliciter que la
commission européenne tiennent bon et
garde le cap en matière de relance verte
alors que nous sommes confrontés à une
crise sanitaire sans précédent et que
l'on a d'ores et déjà entendu des voix
dissonantes appelant à oublier purement
et simplement ce pacte vert néanmoins
bien du chemin reste encore à parcourir
pour mettre tout le monde d'accord
ainsi alors que nous allons disposer de
quelques mois supplémentaires pour
préparer la coop 26
repoussés en 2021 comment pensez vous
que la commission va trouver les moyens
de rallier tous les états membres et
notamment certains pays de l'est je
pense à la pologne et à la hongrie
autour d'objectifs communs
par ailleurs le pacte vert vise-t-il une
politique industrielle équilibrée en
matière de développement des énergies
renouvelables
je lui ai dit au niveau national à
plusieurs reprises j'ai le sentiment que
nous n'avons de cesse de mettre tous nos
oeufs dans le même panier
en focalisant par exemple beaucoup plus
sur l'éolien et en délaissant peut-être
par trond le développement de
l'hydrogène
quelle vision du développement des er
défendra donc la commission quid des
réflexions sur le stockage de l'énergie
autres sujets au coeur du pacte vers la
rénovation énergétique
on n'a de cesse de dénoncer les retards
pris par la france dans ce domaine
j'ai vu que la commission devait évaluer
les stratégies nationales
pourriez vous nous indiquer si ces
évaluations ou commencé et quelle forme
elle fagnes exactement pour conclure que
j'évoquais les transports durables qui
évidemment de grands pans d'une part
conséquente dans ce pacte il va nous
falloir indubitablement revoir nos modes
de transport tant de voyageurs que de
marchandises
au lendemain de cette crise et il me
semble que le canal seine nord pour
lequel on s'est tant battue et qui
soutenu par l'europe s'insère
parfaitement dans les objectifs du pacte
vert et pourrait faire figure d'exemple
merci merci beaucoup ronan dantec
sénateurs rds
merci si on regarde ces dernières années
en europe les succès en terme de baisse
des émissions on voit que c'est souvent
très souvent liée à un prix du carbone
élevée on peut prendre l'exemple de
l'angleterre qui est sorti très
rapidement de la production électrique à
base de charbon à partir d'une taxe
spécifique ou prendre l'exemple de la
mobilité en suède où il ya des succès
intéressants mais avec un prix une
contribution carbone très élevé j'ai
bien entendu monsieur le vice président
que vous parliez d'un nécessaire
mécanisme aux frontières pour protéger
l'économie européenne
est ce dire que vous envisagez d'ores et
déjà vous anticipez une augmentation du
prix du carbone en europe ce soit
le ts de michonne trade system pour les
entreprises ou les contribution carbone
pour les consommations les émissions
domestiques
ce qui pose derrière d'ailleurs la
question de l'opportunité de recettes
un nouvelle pour l'europe et les états
membres parce que là on dépense beaucoup
mais il faut aussi penser à un moment
aux recettes derrière un vous parler de
ce mécanisme mais est ce que l'europe
est prête aujourd'hui au bras de fer
avec la chine sur ces sujets puisque je
vous rappelle que la dernière tentative
sur notamment la taxation du transport
aérien a fini par un plus tôt un recul
de l'europe face à la pression chinoise
donc est-ce que et se dire que d'après
vos propos vous êtes aujourd'hui prêt à
ce bras de fer économique entre l'europe
la chine est probablement les états unis
et deuxième question pour rester dans
cette dimension géopolitique
1 nous ne pourrons pas stabilisée climat
uniquement par l'effort européen
1 il y a effectivement a mené notamment
par les taxes aux carmes
aux frontières les autres grandes
économies majeures à intégrer le prix du
carbone et il ya la question des pays en
développement qui sont aussi les pays
des stocks de carbone et vous avez parlé
un petit peu tout à l'heure de la de la
forêt mais plutôt des forêts primaires
européenne est ce que dans votre
stratégie du new green deal dans la
stratégie globale 1 européenne le
soutient plus affirmée aux pays du sud
et notamment aux pays africains pour
qu'eux aussi soient sur une stratégie un
trajectoire carbone compatible avec
l'accord de paris fait partie de la
stratégie puisque finalement on parle
très peu dans cette sortie de crise du
coc vide des questions de développement
alors que les pays du sud notamment les
pays africains ont énormément souffert
autant que nous voir plus de la crise
actuelle donc qu'est-ce que vous rentrez
cette dimension développement dans la
stratégie européenne
[Musique]
si danielle obono dpt la france
insoumise merci présidente collègue
monsieur le vice-président petit
meersman petit normal s'est excusé moi
je voulais vous interpeller sur la
stratégie
en matière de désinvestissements des
énergies polluantes et notamment des
énergies fossiles à un rapport récent de
l' ocde et de l' agence internationale
de l'énergie montre que en 2019 le
soutien à la production d'énergies
fossiles a globalement augmenté de 38%
au niveau des pays dits développés et
ceux dits émergents et donc y compris au
niveau européen
or ce rapport notre os aussi que la
période actuelle devrait être en fait un
moment pour changer et orienter
différemment les politiques en la
matière nous pensons que face à la crise
sanitaire économique est aussi face à la
crise écologique
il s'agit pas de relancer même en
verdissant ici et là des politiques mais
de bifurquer de manière radicale pour
changer de paradigme et changer le
fonctionnement de l'ensemble de nos
économies or pour le moment l'ensemble
des décisions prises au niveau européen
dans des pays mais également au niveau
de la banque centrale européenne ne
montre pas que la prise de conscience
s'est faite j'en veux pour preuve le
choix fait après le 4 juin après le
conseil des gouverneurs de la banque
centrale européenne de continuer à
financer les énergies fossiles 600
milliards d'euros de doral date de
rachat d'actifs supplémentaires qui
pourrait apporter jusqu'à 90 milliards
aux entreprises les plus polluantes
comme le craignent les organisations non
gouvernementales
riscle and find some mauvaise et 350
points org
et malgré les appels de ses nombreuses
associations et de plusieurs élus à
prendre en compte la question du climat
est l'enjeu climatique dans la décision
de rachat d'actifs
les gouverneurs n'ont pas fait évoluer
la politique de la banque
selon greenpeace les achats de la bce
aurait déjà apporté 7 6 milliards
d'euros aux fossiles depuis le début de
l'épidémie
alors ma question est comment est ce que
dans le cadre du plan et de la stratégie
dite de relance verte qui nous semblent
insuffisantes mais
nous pensons que on peut au moins ça
peut donner
comment est-ce que vous qu'on se
comptait faire changer et intervenir
pour le dévers le désinvestissement
nécessaire dans ces énergies fossiles et
de manière générale dans les secteurs
les plus polluants
merci pierre laurent sénateur sénateurs
serre oui bonjour monsieur le vice
président 1
ma question porte sur la place du
ferroviaire dans le pacte vert à la
politique de la les politiques de la
commission européenne ces dernières
années toutes ces dernières décennies
c'est surtout préoccupés de
déréglementer le secteur du ferroviaire
avec des effets climatiques et
environnementaux particulièrement
délétère
pour prendre un exemple qui concerne la
france le secteur du fret ferroviaire
est le premier à avoir été déréglementés
en france et depuis cette
déréglementation la part du transport
ferroviaire de marchandises a reculé de
moitié dans notre pays et à l'échelle de
l'européenne à l'échelle européenne nous
avons assisté à une explosion du
transport routier de marchandises
al'inverse de l'objectif de
décarbonation qui est maintenant affiché
comme un objectif majeur de l'union
européenne j'ajoute que ces politiques
de déréglementation systématique
ajouté aux politiques de concurrence
telle qu'elle était conçue jusque là ont
conduit à entraver la construction
coopération industrielle européenne dans
le domaine du ferroviaire pour assurer
notre souveraineté en la matière donc ma
question est donc en trois volets
premièrement est-ce que quelle est
l'ambition de reconquête que vous fixé
avec le past pacte vert en matière
de ferroviaire ferroviaire en général et
singulièrement dans le domaine du train
du transport du transport de
marchandises adossés à ces objectifs
s'il existe un quelle est l'ambition de
financement que vous que vous fixé pour
soutenir l'investissement nécessaire la
construction des infrastructures
nécessaires et la reconquête en la
matière si par exemple en france puisque
le pdg de la sncf le nouveau pdg de la
sncf
on a parlé à l'issue de la crise du coc
vide un plan massif d'investissement
dans le fret ferroviaire était décidée
est ce que le pacte vert pourrait
accompagner financièrement cet effort
d'investissement et enfin
dernier volet de ma question est ce que
vous êtes favorable à une révision des
critères de la politique de concurrence
a mise en oeuvre toutes ces dernières
années pour favoriser au contraire des
politiques de construction de
coopération industrielle assurons notre
souveraineté dans ce dans ce secteur
décisif pour lutter contre la pollution
merci merci et yolaine de courson député
écologie démocratie et solidarité
merci à madame la présidente monsieur le
vice président dans un rapport publié le
5 juin dernier la cour des comptes
européenne a jugé inefficace l'impact de
la pac en matière de préservation de la
biodiversité sur le territoire agricole
sur les terres agricoles
ce résultat décevant et le fait
d'exigence de verdissement trop faible
et du manque de suivi des dépenses
décidées à cette mission je pense que
vous serez d'accord avec moi pour dire
que le temps est venu d'allier
agriculture alimentation environnement
et santé globale pour cela nous devons
être plus ambitieux réformer en
profondeur les dispositifs existants
c'est justement une des priorités du
groupe écologie démocratie solidarité
soutenir la transition agro écologiques
en accompagnement la sortie un
accompagnement en accompagnant pardon la
sortie des pesticides et en garantissant
la préservation de la biodiversité des
ressources et des sols en février
dernier la commission européenne a donné
son feu vert au régime des aides
proposées par la france pour le paiement
des services environnementaux
concrètement c'était à se permettre de
revenir l agriculteur qui va être
d'offres des pratiques vertueuses au sol
leur exploitation
les expérimentations ont été menées
notamment dans le finistère est ce que
vous pensez qu'un tel dispositif
pourrait être mis en place au niveau
européen est l'outil national qui se
rapprochait plus de ces paiements dans
la pac actuelle sur les mesures agro
environnementales et climatiques
nécesaire octroyés sont liées à une
obligation de moyens et pas de résultats
cela empêche d'en mesurer l'impact et de
les rendre réellement efficaces comme le
suivent les gens le rapport de la cour
des comptes européenne une obligation de
résultat ça signifie une prise de risque
plus élevé si la rémunération de cette
crise de risque d'autre incitative
alors très peu d'agriculteurs
contracteront des bikes pourquoi ces
dispositifs sur l'astre actifs de
devrait intégrer une prime de risque et
puis surtout lever les contraintes
trois ordres financière car le
financement est pensée comme la
couverture d'un manque à gagner et non
d'une rémunération d'un service rendu
administratif s'il est trop souvent
perçues par les agriculteurs comme des
contraintes supplémentaires il à durée
limitée dans le temps puisqu'il s'agit
de contraintes dues à trois ans sa
pérennité le sont certaines alors je le
disais le temps est venu de réconcilier
agriculture environnement santé globale
pour avoir des outils à la hauteur de
nos ambitions
n'est-il pas l'heure de donner aux
agriculteurs des compensations
financières supérieures aux seuls
surcoût engendré par les mesures à jouer
donc agroenvironnementales véritable
rémunération je vous remercie
merci jérôme bignon sénateurs les
indépendants république et territoires
merci monsieur le président le pacte
vert européen que vous portez doit
rester au coeur de la relance européenne
le 20 mai dernier la commission a
dévoilé deux stratégies celle dite de la
ferme à la table et celles en faveur de
la biodiversité à l'horizon 2030
je suis heureux de les voir mener de
front telle les deux faces d'une même
pièce
les pratiques durables proposés sont
essentiels
qu'elles soient agricoles industrielles
commerciales ou de consommation la
sécurité alimentaire et l'accès à une
alimentation de qualité sont nécessaires
responsable sur mon territoire d'une
banque alimentaire
je ne peux malheureusement qu observer
l'augmentation de mes compatriotes ayant
besoin de s'y rendre depuis le début de
la crise le président pouvez vous nous
expliquer comment la stratégie globale
que vous proposez pourra permettre aux
européens notamment les plus fragiles
d'avoir accès d'alimentation de qualité
j'ai noté que la problématique des zones
humides faisait partie intégrante de la
stratégie from farc stock production en
lien avec la production alimentaire
durable
pouvez vous nous préciser quelles sont
les étapes et les discussions déjà
entamées au sujet du plan d'action pour
la gestion intégrée des nutriments ainsi
que son articulation avec la réforme de
la pac est important plus de s'assurer
d'assurer une alimentation durable de
pouvoir proposer aussi des alternatives
à nos agriculteurs et leur assurer un
niveau de vie décent
enfin monsieur le président le pacte
vert sera financé par le budget européen
auquel sera arrimé le plan de relance
dont la négociation est en cours
l'europe traverse et déjà des moments de
tension avant la pandémie en lien avec
le bric site ou à cause des négociations
relatives au cadre financier pluriannuel
le sommet qui se profile s'avère une
nouvelle fois cruciale quel est l'impact
de la crise sur la mise en place du
pacte vert et de son financement
comment sont appréhendés les idées de
taxes sur les plastiques ou encore le
mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières de l'ue eux afin d'aider au
financement de la relance verte en
europe
je vous remercie c'est andré chassaigne
député gauche démocrate et républicain
andré chassaigne on vous entend pas le
micro
andré chassaigne
vous nous entendez voilà ça vous
m'entendez c'est bon c'est bon merci
excusez moi je n'arrivais pas à le
mettre ce le vice président alors que
nous approuvons aux prémices d'une
terrible crise économique nos camps
s'attendent d'ores et déjà que les taux
d'un des systèmes capitalistes font tout
leur possible pour bloquer la
transformation écologique et sociale de
notre société pour ainsi indispensable à
la survie de notre humanité
en france cette résistance est incarné
par le medef syndicat du patronat est à
l'auguste heures privilégié du
gouvernement dans un document daté du 3
avril son président a ainsi demandé à
notre ministre de la transition
écologique de suspendre l'application de
nouvelles mesures environnementales
impactant les entreprises ils exigent de
revenir sur les maigres avancées
écologiques obtenu dans la loi sur
l'économie circulaire en particulier sur
la création de nouvelles filières
pollueur payeur qui impose aux
professionnels de contribuer
financièrement à la gestion et recyclage
des déchets via leurs produits cet
exemple sans emblématique du combat au
néolibéralisme s'apprête à livrer dans
ce monde post kovy 19
à ce titre le pacte vert devra faire
face à cette résistance productiviste
tout en assurant décès en affrontant
secteurs d'activité dont l'avenir est
conditionnée à l'échec de la mise en
scène transition écologique
je pense ici au secteur bancaire le
sujet rarement évoquée dans le débat
public à l'exception entre autres de
gaël giraud dont les travaux sur ce
point on l'unanimité il rappelle que les
banques européennes ont partie liée avec
la transition écologique beaucoup
d'entre elles ont en effet dans leurs
bilans énormément d'actifs liés aux
hydrocarbures fossiles
si nous décidions de main de fer du
charbon et du pétrole des actifs échoué
c'est-à-dire de les interdire dans le
commerce
ces banques sont parfaitement
conscientes du risque en cours avec la
mise en oeuvre la transition écologique
dès lors dans ce contexte le
greenwashing efira père foire
les plaintes sont mises au vert alors
qu'un réalité elles n'ont aucune
intention de financer selon moi pour de
bon et un niveau suffisant un changement
de société qui signifierait la fin leur
modèle d'affaires actuel en nous savons
que le pacte vert se repose beaucoup sur
l'initiative privée vous l'avais dit
dans ce cadre commun à gym avec un
concours timide des banques et sans
mobiliser suffisamment les prêts permis
par le pacte vert
comment réussir cette transformation
goji à des bancs qui pourrait jouer le
jeu du chantage de la faillite
l'enjeu est de taille puisque pour la
seule période 2009-2010 d'un 2023 les
montants nécessaires à l'atteinte des
objectifs énergétiques et climatiques
français dans le secteur du bâtiment des
transports de la production d'énergie
sont estimés entre 55 et 85 milliards
d'euros par an soit 2,5 à 4 % du pib
merci cher collègue monsieur le vice
président vous avez la parole
et j'aimerais savoir de combien de temps
vous disposez encore puisque nous avons
encore neuf demandes de paroles là bon
jeu je monte je vais rester mais on
m'avait dit que c'était jusqu'à 6 heures
mais bon je je je reste pour répondre à
toutes les attentes les questions et
très aimable et merci alors je je salue
en fait le rapport de la cour des
comptes dont on a fait référence parce
que cela indique deux choses qu'il faut
augmenter notre approche vis-à-vis la
biodiversité c'est pour ça que nous
avons venons de présenter une stratégie
sur la biodiversité et syndicaux si à
mon avis que le changement climatique
est là pour lui l'appauvrissement de la
biodiversité font peser des menaces
imminentes et persistants sur la
sécurité alimentaire et les moyens
d'existence et donc aussi pour
l'existence des agriculteurs les plantes
les animaux y compris les pollinisateurs
et les
organismes du sol il joue un rôle
essentiel dans notre système alimentaire
et la biodiversité est également la base
de régime alimentaire sain et nutritif
et améliore les moyens de subsistance
dans les zones rurales est ainsi aussi
la production agricole et je crois qu'il
faut qu'il faut créer à travers notre
stratégie sur la biodiversité
une alliance entre l'agriculture et la
nature une alliance qui est trop absente
maintenant et oui je bon la commission
donnera sa réaction formelle sur le
rapport de la cour des comptes
mais oui je vois très bien ce que dit la
cour des comptes la cour des comptes
d'ailleurs qui a aussi nous donner un
rapport très critique il ya quelques
mois sur le côté vert de la pac qui a
aussi pas à livrer les résultats dont on
avait besoin donc là vraiment je vois ça
comme comme un devoir essentiel pour le
travail que je fais de marier les
intérêts de la biodiversité
une biographie on risque de perdre un
million d'espèces
c'est très très critique de mariée ça
avec une agriculture soutenable
produisant les aliments qui sont
accessibles pour tout le monde aussi
ceux qui n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent et
donc deuxièmement sur l'hydrogène
la commission est très pragmatique en ce
qui concerne les sources d'énergie
renouvelables
mais on voit des opportunités énormes à
l'échelle européenne et même mondiale
dans le domaine de l'hydrogène cette
heure c'est pour stocker d'énergies
renouvelables c'est pour utiliser comme
source d'énergie directement et ça aussi
ça donne une opportunité par exemple
pour le maghreb et l'afrique du nord 2 à
travers d'énergie solaire de produire un
hydrogène qui pourraient être très
utiles à l'économie européenne du futur
et l'infrastructure qu'on a déjà pour le
gaz naturel
elle pourrait être adapté relativement
facilement pour aussi fournir
l'hydrogène transporté vie trop chère
en plus je vois je crois qu'on a le
devoir de maintenir une industrie de
l'acier en europe l'acier pour l'europe
pour l'industrie européenne
je crois que c'est un secteur essentiel
mais l'acier ne pourra pas survivre s'il
ne devient pas vert est le moyen pour
faire ça c'est d'utiliser l'hydrogène et
c'est possible on n'a pas besoin de
quelques années pour développer ça pour
le marché mais c'est une technologie
possible
c'est un futur possible et je crois une
fois qu'on a un acier verre en europe on
aura eu un avantage concurrentiel
vis-à-vis du reste du monde
énorme donc je crois vraiment il faut
viser là dessus le système et ets il
s'est prouvé même dans cette crise avec
tous toute la baisse du du prix du
carbone etc
le ts a survécu premièrement il a eu une
petite chute du prix mais le prix est à
nouveau à peu près à 20 euros tonne
donc je crois que ce système si on les
labors si on réduit les les droits
gratuits qu'on a donnée si on introduit
d'autres secteurs dans ce système ts je
crois que c'est la meilleure façon pour
mettre un prix sur le carbone et en plus
des revenus qui viennent du dts peuvent
être investis directement pour créer une
économie circulaire est soutenu et je
crois que c'est j'ai déjà mme bon vous
avez parlé du côté international la
chine
il faut il faut il faut se déplacer de
la naïveté sur un politique la chine qui
est une politique qui est devenu plus
agressif et pas très pas très utiles
pour développer des relations
d'amitié sur sur le domaine commercial
mais en même temps je crois que notre
relation avec la chine est essentiel
pour développer aussi des projets pour
décarboniser aussi l'économie chinoise
vers la moitié du siècle l'afrique pour
moi c'est le continent qui dépend de
nous et nous dépendons de ce continent
et je crois si on n'a pas encore compris
en tant qu'européens que notre sort est
étroitement liée au sort de l'afrique
on n'a rien compris donc je crois que
pour cette commission européenne donner
priorité aux relations profondes avec
l'afrique aussi dans le domaine du monde
soutenable dans le domaine du climat
dans le domaine de l'énergie
c'est essentiel et je crois que les
dirigeants africains ont bien compris
que qu on s est mieux qu on veut
vraiment établir une relation entre
égaux entre entre pays qui ont le même
but et qui peut-être sans dents dans un
autre état une autre étape de
développement qui en fin de compte
doivent décarboniser les uns comme les
autres et il vaut mieux faire ça
ensemble j'ai donné l'exemple déjà de
l'hydrogène
je crois que le désinvestissement dans
le l'énergie fossile
ça va très vite maintenant ça va très
vite oui il faudra des décisions par la
banque centrale européenne
une décision qui a déjà été prise par la
bei et autres investisseurs mais je
crois que c'est déjà un processus qui
est en cours parce qu'ils voient qu'ils
vont perdre ses effectifs s'y
investissent dans l'énergie du passé
figurez-vous l'énergie renouvelable et
bon marché et coûte moins cher
aujourd'hui que l'énergie traditionnelle
nous à nous avons l'année des chemins de
fer l'année prochaine est très important
pour la commission européenne d'avoir
une stratégie performante sur les
chemins de fer aussi dans le nom des
transports il faut
créer des des systèmes modulaires de
transport des marchandises
il ya des exemples en europe où ça
marche assez assez bien une échelle
modeste mais ça fonctionne très bien en
suisse en autriche et il faut quand même
qu'on fasse ça à l'échelle européenne
je crois pas que la diminution de frais
doit nécessairement en france voient les
serments est relié à la libéralisation
parce que dans la même période le ferait
en allemagne a augmenté
et c'est quand même un marché déjà
libéralisés donc je crois pas qu'il y
ait un lien un tel lien mais en même
temps je vois la nécessité urgente
d'investir dans dans notre système de
chemin de fer et de créer un système
transport modulaire et ça débloque le
transport routier
ça ça mène à une diminution très très
considérable des des émissions voilà je
j'attends vos prochaines questions merci
beaucoup monsieur le vice-président de
la troisième vague de questions
guillaume chevrollier sénateurs les
républicains monsieur le vice président
de la commission européenne la crise
sanitaire a rappelé la place essentielle
du secteur numérique qui a permis de
maintenir la continuité d'un grand
nombre d'activités économiques
si nous savons que numérique permet
d'éviter des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre il semble plus que jamais
nécessaire de se pencher sur son
empreinte environnementale et ces
externalités négatives consommation
d'énergie émissions de carbone le green
deal prévoit-il des mesures et des
investissements dans une transition
numérique
s'inscrivant pleinement dans le cadre de
la transition écologique et alors que la
fabrication et le transport des
terminaux constituent une part majeure
de l'empreinte carbone du numérique un
mécanisme de barrières écologique sur
les importations serait efficace
quelle action de la commission sur le
sujet et aussi quelles actions de la
commission sur la question de la
souveraineté technologique dans le
domaine du numérique notamment
s'agissant de la 5g
deuxième question la pandémie monsieur
scellier on vous entendez pas est ce que
vous voulez bien reposer votre question
depuis le début je recommence très bien
malheureusement monsieur le vice
président de la commission européenne
la crise sanitaire a rappelé la place
essentielle du secteur du numérique qui
a permis de maintenir la continuité d'un
grand nombre d'activités économiques
et si nous savons que numérique permet
d'éviter des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre il semble plus que jamais
nécessaire de se pencher sur son
empreinte environnementale et ces
externalités négatives que ce soit en
termes de consommation d'énergie ou
d'émissions de carbone
le green deal prévoit-il des mesures et
des investissements pour une transition
numérique
s'inscrivant pleinement dans le cadre de
la transition écologique et alors que la
fabrication d'é et le transport des
terminaux qui constitue une part majeure
de l'empreinte carbone du numérique un
mécanisme de barrières écologique sur
ses importations serait efficace
quelle est l'action de la commission
européenne sur cette question et qui les
laisse moi aussi de la commission sur
les questions autour de la souveraineté
technologique dans le secteur du
numérique
deuxième question la pandémie de lakovic
19 a mis en lumière des liens croissants
entre l'émergence de maladies
zoonotiques et la destruction de nos
écosystèmes la commission de
l'aménagement et de développement
durable du sénat mme pas publier des
recommandations parmi lesquelles figure
un renforcement de la lutte contre le
trafic d'espèces protégées est également
une sensibilisation sur la question de
la déforestation importés
comment la stratégie biodiversité du
green deal intègre-t-elle ces deux
points et enfin monsieur le commissaire
est rapidement relayé l'incompréhension
des agriculteurs suite aux annonces de
la commission sur le pacte vert les
orientations annoncées semblent faire
sans étude d'impact et surtout sans
concertation avec les agriculteurs qui
vous l'avez dit sont des acteurs
essentiels de la biodiversité il
convient vraiment de les associer de les
soutenir et qu'il y ait des moyens
financiers notamment qu'il est plus
d'efficacité sur les prestations
services environnementaux pour les eps
la gestion de l'eau par exemple parce
que l'agriculture est un secteur
essentiel pour permettre la construction
de la société prospère et jusque que
vous souhaitez et vous l'avez dit mais
il faut le faire cette alliance
nécessaire de l'agriculture et de la
nature je vous remercie
merci les lianes un tanguy dpt la
république en marche
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
vice président j'avais une question
concernant les la biodiversité et
notamment à la protection de la
biodiversité marine
la commission européenne souhaite porter
cette biodiversité marine de 11 à 30 %
et sachant que cette biodiversité ne
peut se faire sans le soutien des pays
limitrophes dont certains ne s'érige pas
en modèle je pense notamment au royaume
uni qui sont classés au second rang des
états européens qui pratiquent le plus
la surpêche
contre l'avis des scientifiques je
voulais savoir ce que prévoyait l'union
européenne pour inclure londres dans la
protection de la biodiversité marine
européenne et quelle était la stratégie
anticipé en l'absence d'un accord d'ici
la fin de la période de transition et
j'avais également une seconde question
concernant les les
les partenariats commerciaux il me
semble qu'il ya peut-être une
contradiction des actions de la
commission avec les objectifs
environnementaux qu'elles présentent
on souhaite limiter les conséquences
environnementales de l'activité
économique européenne et les risques
stratégiques et sanitaires mais d'un
autre côté l'union européenne elle
multiplie aussi ses partenariats
commerciaux je pense notamment au
mexique l australie et nouvelle zélande
et au mercosur et ce sans introduire
deux clans de clauses environnementales
et donc je voulais savoir quelles
clauses environnementales contraignantes
qui présente des engagements on va dire
fort inédit l'union européenne prévoit
tel d'intégrer dans ses accords afin de
de maintenir une certaine cohérence
je vous remercie merci claude bérit
débat sénateurs socialistes et
républicains
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
vice-président je souhaite vous
interroger sur la politique des
transports
alors ma première question porte sur les
ambitions que qui sont portées par le
pacte vert européen et le plan de
relance européen matière de
décarbonation des transports terrestres
et plus particulièrement s'agissant du
montant des investissements qui
pourraient être consacrés au
développement des véhicules électriques
et à hydrogène tels que le soutien à des
projets r d à la reconversion des
chaînes de production ou au déploiement
d écriture des infrastructures de
recharge et surtout au développement du
réseau des transports collectifs au
regard des difficultés rencontrées par
la filière automobile
l'ambition de renforcer les normes
d'émissions de polluants atmosphériques
et de réexaminer les normes d'émissions
de co2 des voitures et des véhicules
utilitaires légers
d'ici juin 2000 20 heures est elle
toujours d'actualité
deuxième point les appels à un plan de
relance du secteur du fret ferroviaire
se multiplient en france comme en europe
et je viens avec dix collègues
socialistes de la commission
développement durable de signer une
tribune sur ce plan intitulé le
ferroviaire le grand absent du plan de
relance je veux savoir si des mesures de
soutien au transport ferroviaire de
marchandises sont essais sont prévus
dans le cadre du grand deal et du plan
de relance
quelles pourraient être les contours en
matière d'infrastructures ou des deux
notamment et plus gouvernement quelles
sont les pistes envisagées pour
accompagner la décor banal la
décarbonation pardon du secteur du
transport de marchandises et de
voyageurs
et enfin dernier point le programme
korcia prévoit à l'échelle mondiale la
compensation des émissions du secteur
aérien supérieur aux niveaux enregistrés
en 2019 et en 2020 la commission
européenne
a pourtant proposé que seuls 2019 soit
retenu comme année de référence pour le
calcul des compensations pour tenir
compte de la chute du trafic en 2020
cela ne reviendrait-il pas à vider le
programme de ce contenu
étant donné que le trafic pourrait être
pourrait mettre des années à revenir à
son niveau de 2009
la crise sanitaire n'était elle pas au
contraire l'occasion de donner à corscia
une véritable ambition
merci de vos réponses
michel dupont oui je suis là on vous
entend à l'art c'est à votre tour
d'accord merci beaucoup monsieur le
vice-président effectivement je voulais
intervenir en tant que président du
groupe d'étude sur l'hydrogène à
l'assemblée nationale donc nous avons
réussi risque dernier nous avons 70 des
nuitées qui tresse partisans qui en font
partie et donc je voulais assister sur
ce dossier de l'hydrogène effectivement
je crois si j'ai encore en france on a
des descendeurs et une recherche et
développement en pointe mais nous avons
toujours le problème du lien avec
l'industrie et la mise en application en
termes de massification donc je compte
sur l'europe pour nous aider justement
aller dans ce sens parce que mon livre
au gène c'est un problème de gouttes
encore mais c'est véritablement l'avenir
c'est vraiment une technologie de
rupture pour de même pour le futur et
c'est encore plus mis en exergue avec la
crise à uniterre et mourut en de vivre
en terme de relocalisation dominèrent
génétique de la france et de l'europe
donc c'est ce sujet je voudrais
souligner et en même temps savoir si
vous pourriez de recevoir un bureau
d'études
ah oui celle dans l'émoi chez moi merci
merci d'agréer milliers sénateurs les
républicains
décidemment on a vraiment des problèmes
techniques
daniel gremillet vous nous entendez
mais ces graminées
voilà c'est à vous merci monsieur vice
président dans le cadre des travaux que
je conduis au sein de la commission des
affaires économiques du sénat
nous avons publié une série de
préconisations pour relancer notre
économie en accélérant sadek harmonisée
je suis ton très intéressé par les
mesures essentielles que la commission
portant ce sens pour ce qui concerne le
mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières de l'union européenne qui est
primordial pour permettre à nos
industriels de maintenir des standards
environnementaux avaient tout en les
protégeant du dumping
quelles en sont à ce stade et contours
et le calendrier
à quelles conditions ce mécanisme
peut-il être compatibles avec les règles
découlant de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce
s'agissant des investissements publics
devant être soutenus dans le cadre du
pacte vert la commission a prévu qu'il
respecte un serment vers est de ne pas
nuire
quel est le degré de normativité de
cette disposition est elle synonyme
d'une conditionnalité des aides
si tel était le cas ce ne serait pas
contre productif pour la transition
énergétique car peu adapté aux réalités
économiques
pour ce qui est du fonds de transition
juste qui est crucial pour accompagner
les reconversions socio économique
c'est leur revalorisation annoncée de
32.5 milliard d'euros aura-t-elle une
incidence sur les critères d'éligibilité
les régions et les activités concernées
pour le moins limité en france seront l
étendue d'eau traçant annonces ont été
faites par la commission dans le cadre
du pacte vert tels que la mobilisation
du fonds en misant que l'europe en
faveur des techniques technologie
essentielle vers une énergie propre est
celle du plan d'investissement pour
l'europe en faveur de la rénovation
énergétique les mobilités durables
quelles sont leurs montants
non précisée par dans la communication
de la communication et enfin une
question plus z'agricoles comment
pensez-vous faire cohabiter le pacte
vert avec la nécessité d'avoir une
nourriture et garantissant à la
population pas forcément à 20% de la
population qui est en mesure de se payer
mais à la globalité la population
européenne
une certitude que l'on va pas fragiliser
et renforcer les importations venant en
dehors de l'union européenne comment
faire cohabiter l'agriculture européenne
avec sa capacité à nourrir la population
sans distorsion de concurrence
extra européenne merci et la dernière
question pour didier geoffroy député
européen du groupe
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
vice président de la commission
la crise du coc vide et ses conséquences
n'ont pas diminué mais bien renforcé la
nécessité d'une transition écologique et
de la mise en oeuvre du pacte vers la
reconstruction et la relance doivent
être assurément écologique
tout comme elles doivent être numérique
pour que cela soit concrètement possible
le 27 mai dernier nous savons la
présidence de la commission européenne
ue que cela intervienne a présenté un
plan de relance particulièrement
audacieux de 750 milliards d'euros pour
la première fois c'est la commission qui
va emprunter en son nom propre et non
plus les états morin qui dît en train
d'y remboursement et la question des
modalités de remboursement est essentiel
à mes yeux corps car sans financement
pas d'action et donc pas de relance pour
pouvoir rembourser les montants
empruntés
la commission a indiqué qu'en plus des
états membres une partie devrait
s'effectuer par des ressources propres
nouvellement constituée parmi elles
figurent des mécanismes de compensation
qui seront payées par les entreprises
non européennes je pense par exemple à
la taxe carbone sur les frontières que
j'appelle évidemment de mai vous j'ai en
revanche une interrogation
sur une autre ressource propre possible
évoquée dans les documents de la
commission et qui semble cette fois
concerné les entreprises européennes la
communication de la commission du 27 mai
évoque en effet je cite une nouvelle
ressource fondée sur les activités des
grandes entreprises qui tirent des
bénéfices considérables du marché alors
monsieur le commissaire est au fond ma
question s'adresse surtout à vous en
tant que premier vice-président de la
commission
est ce à dire que parmi les ressources
propres envisagées et qui permettront
notamment cette relance verte se dessine
la perspective d'un impôt sur les
sociétés européennes en plus de ceux
déjà existants au niveau national et au
fond si demain les personnes morales
européenne se voyait ponctionner
fiscalement par la commission
qu'est ce qui nous garantit que ce
seront pas demain les citoyens européens
eux mêmes les personnes physiques qui se
verront imposer un impôt européen
je vous remercie monsieur le
vice-président merci de répondre à
toutes ces questions ont j'en ferai de
mon mieux mais je vous dis déjà
certaines questions sont très en détail
mes collègues mes collaborateurs ont
bien noté toutes les questions vous
auriez vous aurez des réponses par écrit
parce que je ne suis pas en mesure de
répondre en détail sur toutes les
questions
j'espère que vous pourriez accepter une
réponse par écrit alors bon je jeu
insiste l'attendait j'ai maintenant je
vais faire du monde papier voilà la
transition numérique fait partie
intégrante du green deal ont déjà la
transition numérique se fait aussi
l'objet d'une on a même pas parlé mais
on est en 1
en plein en pleine révolution
industrielle et le numérique fait partie
de ça la crise climatique et qu'ovide
viennent ensemble avec sept autres cet
autre enjeu pour une europe qui dans le
monde devient plus petit
nous ne serions que 4% de la population
mondiale donc langer pour nos sociétés
européennes pour pour les valeurs que
représente pour nous l'europe est énorme
et on a besoin d'un développement
numérique pour pouvoir créer des emplois
nouveaux pour pouvoir créer une
concurrence sur la base de nos valeurs
sur la base de notre volonté de protéger
la société civile de protéger aussi un
système social qui est voulu par la
grande majorité des citoyens européens
et pour ça la transition numérique est
aussi important que la transition vers
va de va de pair avec une transition
vers une société soutenable et c'est
pour ça que les investissements que nous
envisager envisageant dans ce domaine
sont très très considérable
je crois aussi que le cas la pandémie a
démontré une fois pour toutes que notre
relation avec le monde avec le monde
avec notre environnement ne font que ça
pue ne fonctionne plus je répète cette
pandémie est la conséquence parce qu'on
est on est plus en équilibre avec la
nature et c'est pour ça que je crois
qu'il faut insister avec force sur la
lutte contre le trafic des espèces rares
il faut il faut introduire ça dans nos
accords commerciaux
il faut introduire l'interdiction
d'importation à certains moments de
produits qui ont été créés par
déforestation il faut commencer par
indiquer sur
les étiquettes quand un produit a été
créé par déforestation il faut
convaincre nos partenaires commerciaux
mercosur et autres que une économie
basée sur déforestation n'aura pas plus
de futur et s'éteint c'est un danger
pour tout le monde ce sont des et biens
publics mondiaux dont on parle ici donc
là je crois que c'est important
d'insister aussi dans nos relations avec
nos partenaires en dehors de l'europe
voilà pour cette audition que vous avez
pu suivre sur notre antenne
n'hésitez pas à consulter notre site
internet pour lire tous les articles de
la rédaction www.publicsenat.fr
vous pourrez lire l'article de françois
vignal qui revient sur cette audition
avec ce titre le pacte vert reste notre
boussole
rien n'a changé assure france timerman
ce c'est la fin de cette émission merci
à vous de l'avoir suivi très bonne suite
des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires